Witnesses say they heard Tremors on the
mountain before it gave way late Sunday
as residents were sleeping rescue
workers are trying to reach this trapped
in more than 100 houses buried under the
Earth survivors say they've lost
everything
the only thing I can say is that I'm so
sad so crushed that I don't even know
what to say I'm so sad about my mother
and how she used to serve me food every
time I came here and now there is
nothing
weeks of heavy rain before the landslide
swept roads and bridges away president
Guillermo lasso declared a state of
emergency in 14 provinces affected by
extreme weather and an earthquake
earlier this month
he promised to visit a lousy to meet
Landslide survivors
we are monitoring what is happening with
the weather there to try to visit them
today however the government is fully
active focused on the tragedy in alausi
Ecuador's rain season lasts another two
months people living in homes left
standing in Alaska are hoping what's
left of this mountain won't collapse
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera